agárrense los sombreros porque esto va a
ir rápido muy rápido estamos en Dakar
Chanel presenta su colección
2022 2023 ante 850 invitados entre ellos
550 artistas y personalidades africanas
[Música]
una colección metía Dark desde hace 20
años por iniciativa de Carl lagerfield
la etiqueta de la doble c rinde homenaje
al saber hacer de los plumajeros
bordadores sombrederos comprados por
Chanel cuya dirección artística está
asegurada hoy por la discreta virginidad
se trata de algo excepcional ya que es
la primera vez que una marca de lujo
desfila en el África subsahariana
celebrar en acá tiene sentido porque hay
un saber hacer preciso conectado con los
demás y Beijing está realmente en este
proceso lo entiende y combina estas
cosas también permite a todos los
creadores y megaleses tener una
perspectiva global
Dakar es la capital cultural de África
occidental de la moda del cine Chanel
Envía una señal fuerte al hacer su
primer desfile aquí en Dakar Por qué
Dakar donde Chanel no tiene ningún
interés aparente el 2022 el grupo ha
declarado un volumen de negocio de
14.500 millones de euros puede
permitirse invertir donde no se espera
Aunque ellos suponga arriesgarse a
acusaciones de apropiación cultural o
neocolonialismo financió la renovación
de la antigua Palacio de justicia de
Dakar donde se celebran durante tres
días las fiestas culturales en torno al
desfile también emprende un programa
medioambiental de apoyo a los
agricultores de San Luis y casamans en
resumen una inversión en todos los
frentes descubrió algunos artistas
increíbles cuando vine aquí mix obre
este cantante magistral cuando empezó a
cantar se me puso la piel de gallina
había una emoción loca y ya estábamos
ahí y fue absolutamente mágico sentimos
que algo está pasando de verdad y ver
que hoy el mundo empieza a volver los
ojos hacia nosotros es una satisfacción
especial Es la primera vez que vengo a
atacar Así que estoy descubriendo esta
estos colores teníamos bailarines
raperos al mismo tiempo se está
celebrando un festival de cine del que
Chanel es socio Sí hay una verdadera
efervescencia en este momento Chanel
eran abiertos y sensibles a la joven
creación africana tuvimos nuestro primer
presidente leopol sedarse en Word un
poeta los primeros cineastas africanos
fueron senegaleses senegal siempre ha
sido un país de cultura y la colección
muy años 70 virginidad ha reinterpretado
todos los códigos de la casa tweets
bolsos acolchados camelias cadenas
Perlas una colección salpicada de
referencias africanas pero realizada
totalmente en los talleres de la mesonda
de Chanel en Francia en la creación
y lo encuentro muy fluido
[Música]
realmente tiene esta Pasión por la
artesanía Es realmente un debate
creativo moviendo el diálogo entre París
el estudio cambón el saber hacer y dacar
le surgen miles de ideas y nuevos deseos
puede empezar con un dibujo un boceto
ponemos algo en él nuestra alma en
alguna parte los artesanos senegaleses
en realidad no participaron pero aún así
hay que celebrarlo durante unos meses ya
que Chanel tiene previsto trasladar sus
talleres de arte a dacar para realizar
un intercambio con actores locales
la colección estuvo fascinante no me
esperaba ese resultado el trabajo sobre
los colores el aspecto de los pantalones
todos los niños las influencias en la
pedrería y Las joyas fue fascinante
hacer un desfile aquí con respecto tiene
sentido en el extranjero suele haber
desfiles pero aquí participaron todas
las comunidades los bailarines los
músicos los artistas
fue mágico
so much han pasado tantas cosas oímos
una música Bella cautivadora y vimos
modelos hermosas caminando delante de
nosotros
esta colección es un Crisol de emociones
virginidad Ha logrado una síntesis
Perfecta de todos estos elementos
los colores y materiales que ha elegido
son preciosos
este es probablemente su espectáculo más
bello porque puede sentir toda la
energía de sus influencias
y creo que había un enorme Lienzo en
blanco en el que podía materializar sus
ideas y expresar plenamente su talento
creativo la colección es siempre Un
sueño hubo un look que me pareció
absolutamente
elegante lo maravilloso Es que Chanel
lleva tres años trabajando en este
espectáculo ha conocido a muchos
artistas y es circular todos se inspiran
mutuamente
me conmovió mucho creo que virgini
siempre es muy buena hablando a las
mujeres se preocupa por todas y creo que
todas nos reconocemos esta conexión para
mí es muy poderosa la última silueta es
un vestido negro muy suelto hay una
especie de movimiento en este vestido
que es muy largo hay algo que juega
entre las transparencias como un sueño
fue muy emotivo
[Música]
como puede verse el África subsahariana
es el nuevo El Dorado para las empresas
de lujo en procesos de reinvención